salut c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on va
parler de gaming d'axor gaming on va
parler du casque steelseries article
prohibe est ce un casque de gamer un
casque a l'air d'être franchement super
foot pour game est un accessoire qui
peut franchement déchiré donc ce qu'on
va faire c'est que ce casque on va le
tester on va regarder s'il coule on va
regarder comment il fonctionne et on va
regarder s'il est vraiment top pour les
gamers
oui ou non il va maintenant
première chose à faire quand on teste un
projet comme celui-là c'est de regarder
ce qu'il ya dans la boîte comment il est
fichu plutôt sympa package bienfait
énorme casque il pèse son poids il a
l'air vraiment vraiment cali super rambo
et qu'est-ce qu'on a ensuite à
l'intérieur le bottier pour gérer la
connexion sans fil entrées/sorties l'usb
optique est identique à août en dessous
des accessoires qui sont là et là vous
avez tous les câbles vous avez une
petite batterie usb audio power kéba
mbaye charging qu'ibm 'mobile' audio
qu'ibm petite mousse pour le micro je
suppose plus un câble optique qui s'est
caché là ça c'est super complet vous
avez aussi un guide d'information avec
toutes les infos à connaître sur votre
produit les cas comment ça se branchent
que c'est comment ça marche
hop ah ouais ça ferme les oreilles ça
vous tient c'est ouf c'est incroyable ce
que je vous propose c'est d'aller
rencontrer un vrai gamer pour parler
avec lui d'un casque gaming
ça me paraît être plutôt cool assez
incroyable allez on y va
et nous voilà dans l'autre du gamer qui
arrive c'est ça va bien je vous présente
arnaud arnaud
déjà vu on a déjà sur des vidéos
ensemble arnaud il à la chaîne sur
youtube les mémos n'était rien par de
science de culture de près les choses
comme ça allez voir vous dans la
description qui vous aussi en rien la
fin bonjour les curieux dont carlo à une
autre casquette il à la casquette du
gamer et du coup je me suis dit quitte à
essayer ce casque autant faire appel à
un spécialiste
et pour le coup j'ai aussi un
spécialiste ou la main donc voilà
[Musique]
de prime abord comment tu trouves quand
tu là restée hier quand tu l'as pris en
main alors déjà d'accord pour me remet
en bas on voit que c'est solide
il ya une coque adultes dans un fait
c'est un truc qui vient sur les toits
c'est le truc qui a pas me péter dans
les doigts le jour où il vient me
chercher sur bureau quoi tant mieux
parce que je me suis énervé ont fait ça
quand tu es déjà un clavier pas de la
marque
ouais j'ai un clavier de la marque a
déjà de steelseries donc sec ce qui est
super
et ça c'est bien ça je les pose étage
les branchés en minute ouais franchement
j'ai manche en deux minutes reconnu
directement par le logiciel le
steelseries parce qu'ils ont un logiciel
qui gère les claviers mais qui gère
aussi bas tout ce qui est quasi souris
est en fait du coup bas à peine j'ai
branché direct il l'a détecté m'a dit
attention mise à jour et demi tout
l'effrayant à jour c'est par des
liaisons directes c'est parti direct
l'installation franchement à deux
minutes
ok alors on suit l'expérience le côté
vraiment cool c'est ça tu poses la voilà
donc déjà un niveau son détachement
isolé tu es vraiment bien j'ai par
contre à l'oreille qui j'ai des grandes
oreilles ça ça englobe bien ouais en
fait alors ça suppose c'est pas ça se
pose pas sur l'oreille souvent légaux
des casques un peu gamer qui sont
entrées de gamme etc ont tendance à un
peu écrasée l'oreille on coupe dans ce
pas très agréable c'est quand tu vas sur
l'oreille ça tapis pendant des heures
parce que généralement quand une bonne
session tu es decir de trois heures
minimum pourquoi en fait voilà pour
commencer pour ce qui est du coup et
aval aux oreilles la lame au clash et
que niveau supérieur
j'adorais le côté micro s'est inventé un
film honnête dessus web et en micro en
fait tu peux le sortir et la rentrée et
ça c'est top
ces trucs tous battus et d'écouter un
film téoz et tranquille ok hop tu rabat
est posée tessa jane pas ça c'est bien
adacore et lui règlent la fonction comme
tu es est vrai super souple non croyants
et à la petite bonne est pour éviter la
respiration un petit peu de bijoux phase
de sous genres quand tu es en train de
jouer la nef les oreilles quand c'est sa
séquence avec tes potes exaucé bons
trades respironics nantes à la bonette
et puis un système réfugiés peut-être
que j'allume serait sympa il enfin
c'était pas mal aussi sur sur l'allumage
c'est que tu as
chronique en bluetooth aussi tout ça on
en parlera mais en gros pour l'allumage
situe là sous les oreilles pour
l'allumer ou l'éteindre tu as le
bluetooth en dessous et lui les creux
d'un bouton qu'ils ressortent sans
relief était d'accord qu'est ce qui fait
que quand il va à la main tu le sens ce
que tu vas là est un avantage aussi
c'est que voilà un micro est coupée et à
un système tapis juste vers lui d'un
karaoké
donc en fait tu peux l'éteindre d'un
d'un clic ça c'est vraiment ou school
enfin et là il n'ya pas à dire il est
top et les tu vois la gelée je vais me
lancer à peine je l'allumé dia qui
synchronise ça c'est aussi hallucinant
directement et avec anne hathaway joël
normalement il annonce 12 m de portée
mais avec avec le casque quand tu te
déplaces c'est tout bête amstrad joue
effectivement aller petit post bio j'ai
fait du jeu de bouger et où tu pars avec
ton casque alors mois l'appartement un
peu grand effectivement il tient bien
les 12 m c'est ça c'est clair
après effectivement j'ai des gros mur
donc ça peut samassa et couper leurs
comptes avantage c'est que tu reviens
des tarifs à porter il synchronise
direct soit a pas de temps de latence
quand il n'y a pas c'est vraiment une
communication directe
ok cool ça c'est vraiment bien il ya
autre chose de bien aussi c'est quand
écoles et dans ton jeu généralement et
ton téléphone sonne c'est un peu galère
parce que la pause et on casse je veux
dire aux gars attendait machin etc à
répondre à madame parce que tu appelles
là davantage avec ce casque c'est qui
synchronise aussi en bluetooth
d'accord mais il faut savoir qu'il est
synchronisé avec donc l'appareil qui
connecte à l'ordinateur et le bluetooth
peut se connecter aussi en même temps
alors déconnecté comment là-dessus
attendent langues
alors dites est connecté inde en plus
déconnectés au boîtier royal s ok donc
un genre l'ouïe fine tout simplement
et il ya une connexion situe peu après
faire en bluetooth avec son téléphone
iphone ton téléphone ou à notre ordi ou
autre chose et l' avantage avec ce
système la cdat ressentons mort dit tu
lances dessus après derrière tu connais
ton téléphone dessus cahier des camps
téléphone sonne davantage que tu as
c'est que lui il coupe le son
l'ordinateur est ton micro il se lit pas
sur le téléphone
tu peux répondre au téléphone avec mon
micro avec ton micro là tu ta micro et
casque s'il veut que si tu en prennes
partie enfin taper la geek 115 jouer
temps plein d'action [ __ ] merde j'ai
téléphone qui sonne téléphone sonne déjà
d'une tu l'entends
sinon tu n'entendrait pas si les psys
passé bonne s'y passait pas dedans
tu prends ton téléphone tu réponds et
l'air de rien très connectée en fait
avec ton téléphone tu tape la discute en
train de jouer et l'hectare accroché
boom le jeu reprend et à nouveau le son
est visuel un visuel de toujours en sa
permet de continuer à jouer
c'est pratique c'est vraiment pratique
ok pour un gamer c'est en pratique après
pareil tout ce qui est sûr le cas ce qui
est vraiment bien au tour donc comme je
disais tout à l'heure le côté micro donc
là on voit bien qu'il activait
l'avantagent c'est que des comptes
désactive
ça fait du rouge et visuellement tu as
toujours une fois de l'oeil qu'il voit
quoi je sais si les couples pas un micro
et paraît qu'en train train de jouer tu
veux monter son et descendre le son une
petite molette dessus les toits
tout comme ça tu te poses en fait tu
c'est très instinctif tu l'a vraiment en
main et là tu sens vraiment le côté
quand tu veut allumer ou éteindre en
fait tu l'as tu sens vraiment la
différence par rapport aux boutons et ça
c'est l'autre est décollée attention au
cross le micro est pas mal j'ai testé un
peu en jeu là avec des collègues d'un
micro lien on peut démonter directement
les honnêtes ça se décante super
facilement face à tirer dessus
c'est pas utiliser sa balle utilité de
ça c'est que tout bête me tue pas
tu peux y ait enlevé c'est que si un
jour il y en a une qui qui prend cher ou
quoi que ce soit ça peut changer après
pareille autonomie aussi autonomie 10
heures les batteries sachant qu'un à
deux donc en fait le temps qu'on en a
une dans celui ci on pouvait trouver
changée en charge des risques et là
dessus il ya le boîtier en fait de
réceptions en carrière donc sur le
boîtier comme tu peux le voir sur la
vidéo
en fait le boîtier comme ça de su
dompter une molette qui permet de régler
ton casque et cetera par rapport à la
molette des options de configuration et
sur le côté en fait un petit logement
qu'on me remette à batterie qui pensant
la charge ok et à deuxième qui est
dedans
en sachant que pour échanger c'est tout
simple c'est aimanté elle cache qui est
monté dessus le cash film anglais gk la
patrie et à la batterie là pour les
tabacs tritscher mais l'autre rideau le
cash en plus tu poses la fille quand sa
place directe je pense
j'avais un peu peur au début je dois les
trucs aimanté comme ça ça devient à
moitié et non y tient vraiment bien
qualité audio bien l'été audio ira
là-bas il ya un navire soit qualité
audio c'est incroyable c'est du sept
points dedans alors malheureusement
actuellement on a des jeux qui va tous
les jeunes gèrent fall sept points des
jeux type rpg qu'il très connu lui il
gère donc c'est intéressant sur des jeux
comme ça tu peux arriver djamena moi je
crois sinon pas vraiment une
spécialisation en fait on voit la taille
spécialisation il permet en fait
vraiment
tendre là on va tirer dessus par exemple
de jeu fps beaucoup plus précisément que
entendre qu'on tire à gauche et on tire
à droite
non là on tire un peu à l'arrière droite
on l'entend c'est vraiment à coeur de
réagir plus rapidement est vraiment calé
dans le jeu est arrivé à beaucoup plus
réactif ok ça peut faire la différence à
ce niveau là c'est un produit que tu
recommandes pas ça a pris je commanderai
notamment ah oui franchement en art bien
en règle générale pas la mare cseries
bah voilà le casque je découvre
aujourd'hui donc et aujourd'hui hier je
l'essayé me l'a prêté mais effectivement
je le conseille totalement pour les
joueurs ça peut créer une vraie
plus-value puis franchement confort quoi
le grand fort sur les oreilles tout ça
c'est donc les tops et ses solides parce
que personnellement là comme tu disais
tu ne rendent l'expérience series voilà
j'ai un clavier steelseries j'en suis
content ça fait six mois que je les vois
l'appareil 7 foot son prix mais on sait
pourquoi on met de l'argent dedans et on
est tranquille pour un bon bout de temps
après le seul petit point négatif je
peux donner aux casques
c'est ce petit réglage en fait on peut
régler pour le casque c'est pour régler
les ch'ti site et pour que ça tu es
poussé pousse bien tonton cannes ouais
en fait tout ce truc
un petit peu moyen c'est cet effet un
peu strache en eau pour le régler sa
chambre pour ne pas trop leur idée sur
la tête du cou donc il faudrait qu'une
fois deux fois trois fois pour qu'on
m'aide bien mais bon ça c'est pareil
aussi une fois après environ qu'il voit
là c'est vraiment un détail bon tu n'as
pas été payés pour fait dire du bien ce
qu'il sait risque confie un enfant ne
suis pas payé non plus où l'homme ça ok
bon nombre ont conduit mon poids du cool
bombay pour mercy nationaux merci à toi
merci à vous d'avoir créé cette vidéo
comme d'hab vous invite à laisser des
jolies pouce pour arnaud pour le casque
pour tout le monde c'était c'est génial
et à vous abonner et à vous abonner vous
abonner bien évidemment pour qu'on reste
connecté vous éventail toujours plus de
teck de produits pourquoi pas aussi de
casque gaming de produits gaming c'est
plus intéressant
et puis il ya ce moment là on fera appel
à arnaud qui nous en parlera bien mieux
que moi donc merci a vous soyez sages
vous restez voter parce que vous allez
voir dans quelques temps il ya plein de
surprises qui arrive la rentrée va être
hyper riches
donc on reste ensemble merci merci merci
et adieu à wellington
[Musique]